My legs ache lock or have to climb steps.
It does not stop me from walking and doing my exercises my right leg.
I believe as some neuropathy as a result of the chemotherapy.
I received back in 2020.
Could the aching indicate vascular problems?
What do you recommend?
Yes, so the leg aching could indicate intermittent claudication.
It could indicate some weakness of the heart.
So the questions that a practitioner should ask is an examination should reveal
does this person have swelling in their legs?
So if it's accompanied by swelling, then it's you think more of inability to drain.
So you that could be a function of the heart.
It could also be a function of the lymphatic drainage from the leg.
For instance, there could be a lot of problems.
There could be a lot of causes of that.
And it could be, let's say, the person had, you know, if they're older,
and they have some sagging of some of the intestines, putting pressure on the inferior vein of cave.
At the iliac veins, then that could cause some swelling and leg aches.
So there's lots of possibilities.
Some general nutritional possibilities could range from hydration, a loss of electrolytes.
So decreasing in sodium, decreasing calcium, magnesium, your electrolytes.
So especially during the summer days, if you're out and you're, and you're burning a lot of your minerals,
and you're sweating, you can end up with some, you know, mild dehydration and decrease in electrolytes.
And that could be an issue too.
So lots of, for that, you definitely want to think of a local practitioner to, to take a look at some of those possibilities that I discussed.
But you run up the point of chemotherapy.
So chemotherapy can be an issue too because chemotherapy is highly toxic substance,
and can settle in your tissues.
Now why do people end up with neuropathy from chemotherapy?
Because of the blood flow, when that, when that chemotherapy is flowing through your blood,
and it gets out into the tissues, it's harder to detoxify things from your extremities than it is from, you know, organs that are closer to the heart.
And chemotherapy is toxic to neurons, so it can damage neurons.
And more specifically, it's damaging the sensory receptors.
And the, what are called the large, afferent, large diameter, afferent nerve fibers.
That's how and why a person ends up with their opathy from chemotherapy.
There's a device called the rebuilder that we do sell in the store.
It's a device that's an FDA approved device for neuropathy for either diabetic neuropathy or chemotherapy induced neuropathy.
But also with chemotherapy, you got to think of doing some, some, some, some,
chelation work to try to pull that out, that the person has bad neuropathy from the tumor therapy.
It's a hard one to deal with, you have, you have the benefit of having the ion pro wave at the right, that could be a real big help.
I would say that should be your first thing that you should start with is doing more of the ion pro wave programs that you can look at the general ion pro wave programs with the right.
This would have neuropathy, I'd say, and do the clear line detox.
That's been the most helpful for chemotherapy induced neuropathy.